monsieur écoutez je vous demande pardon
encore deux questions et c'est terminé
pour l'intérieur fourneyron le progrès
de lyon
c'est le président les résistants de la
région rhône alpes ont été péniblement
surpris d'apprendre que paul touvier qui
s'était tristement illustré dans notre
région et qui a été condamné deux fois à
mort avaient bénéficié d'une grâce
présidentielle et il avait également
bénéficié d'une remise des peines
accessoires de l'interdiction de séjour
et de confiscation de biens est il un
discret monsieur le président de vous
demander les raisons qui ont motivé
votre geste
je vous remercie de votre question si
vous l'aviez pas posée je leur ai soul
tout d'abord les faits ce monsieur
touvier a été condamné à mort à la
libération par contumace je suppose que
tous les français savent que ça veut
dire qu'ils ne s'est pas présenté à
l'audience
il se cache et la chancellerie considère
et à considérer c'est qu'on a su à mort
par contumace était prescrite
la lyre qu'elle n'avait plus d'existence
donc le problème ne m'a pas été posée il
n'aurait d'ailleurs pas pu l'être car je
ne peux pas gracié des condamnés par
continue donc ma grasse a consisté
unique en releveur a relevé monsieur
touvier l'interdiction de séjour et de
la confiscation de ses biens officiel en
l'espèce la procession en indivision
d'une maison avec quatre ou cinq ferries
ce dossier
les traiter l effet ramené exactitude
mais par contre je ne l'est pas relevé
de ses droits civiques et d'un très
grand nombre d'incapacité
il est toujours frappé de ce qu'on
appelle la mort de civils alors on m'a
demandé de me justifier voire de
révoquer ma décision
même des juristes le droit de grâce
n'est pas un cadeau fait au chef de
l'état pour lui permettre d'exercer ses
fantaisies
c'est une responsabilité parfois
effrayant on lui impose et qui prend au
vu des dossiers bien su est seul avec sa
conscience et la tradition et le devoir
l'empêchent et de s'expliquer et bien
sûr de revenir sur ses décisions
imaginez ce que ça donnerait dans
d'autres cas une collation à mort par
exemple ce qui ne veut pas dire que la
grâce constitue une absolution de la
faute ni que si peu que ce soit elle
diminue la pitié où le respect qu'on
doit aux victimes
elle est purement et simplement un acte
de clémence et c'est tout mais si je ne
m'explique pas et si je ne peux ni ne
veux revenir sur cette décision
ce puits par contre vous indiquer
quelques réflexions comme ont inspiré
les réactions que j'ai reçus par d'un
très nombreux courriers souvent
émouvants et auquel je n'ai pas répondu
individuellement mais grâce à cette
question je peux y répondre
collective notre pays depuis un peu plus
de 30 ans a été
le drame national en drame national ce
fut la guerre des fêtes et ses
humiliations l'occupation et ses ordres
la libération par contre-coup
l'épuration et ses excès
reconnaissant le et puis la guerre
d'indochine
et puis là froid confie d'algérie et ses
horreurs
des deux côtés et l'exode là mais l'ong
française chassés de leurs foyers et du
coût low as et ses attentats et ces
violences
et par contre coup la répression alors
ayant été figurez-vous dénoncée par les
gens de vichy à la police allemand ayant
échappé deux fois un attentat bloess
tentative une fois aux côtés du général
de gaulle et l'autre fois moins destinée
je me sens le droit de dire alors nous
éternellement entretenir saignante les
plaies de nos désaccords nationaux le
moment n'est-il pas venu de jeter le
voile d'oublier ces temps où les
français ne s'aimait pas s'entre
déchirer et même s'entretuer et je ne
dis pas ça même s'il ya ici des esprits
forts par calcul politique
je le dis par respect de la france